aside from humans in particularly your
humble narrator what primate species
spends the least amount of time climbing
gelada monkeys have liked us adapted for
a life spent mostly on the ground this
has produced some unique aspects of
gelada anatomy society and sex that's
right this is about monkey sex strap in
many primates indicate sexual readiness
with swollen red behinds because geladas
often sit another method emerged their
eye catching chests are thought to play
the same role that an attractive
posterior plays for many other primate
species I say why can't it be both their
society is organized around a dominant
male and a harem of multiple females the
females loyalties are fickle however and
power struggles often occur this is
essentially reality television this is a
familiar scene for geladas a younger
male challenging the incumbent alpha
just there even when you're fighting you
gotta have that flowing mane am i right
he's successful and wins the harems
allegiance for now anyway so there you
have it the gelada baboon I'm sorry
there's a lot of monkey you may see on
the internet that sometimes they're
called baboons they're not true baboons
don't leave a comment pointing that out
that we made a mistake you know what
they are for National Geographic okay
carry on
[Music]